francia toma medidas drásticas con el
gigante suramericano el primer ministro
anunció que no se podrá viajar desde y
hacia brasil hasta nueva orden
vemos que la situación está empeorando y
por eso hemos decidido suspender los
vuelos entre brasil y francia hasta
nuevo aviso
desgraciadamente le recuerdo a la
asamblea nacional que brasil se
encuentra en medio de una situación
absolutamente dramática el peligro de la
variante brasileña crea dificultades
reales
así se veían los aeropuertos de francia
poco después del anuncio algunos
viajeros lograron tomar sus vuelos antes
de que entrara en vigor la medida y a
pesar de lo que dice el gobierno todavía
hay escépticos sabemos que existe la
variante pero no tenemos la impresión de
que sea más contagiosa o más mortífera y
además yo tampoco la había escuchado en
francia pues hablaban de la británica y
la sudafricana pero no decían que la
brasileña era una variante más peligrosa
o más contagiosa la preocupación del
gobierno francés se debe a que la
situación sanitaria en brasil ha
empeorado desde febrero a raíz de la
aparición de una variante local llamada
p 1 considerada más contagiosa y más
mortal pero todavía con poca presencia
en francia pues supone apenas el 0.4 por
ciento de los contagios en el país
en días pasados médicos franceses
aseguraron que la variante brasileña es
probablemente más resistente a las
vacunas y advirtieron al gobierno que la
única solución para impedir su
propagación era la suspensión de los
vuelos desde y hacia brasil el virus en
este país ha colapsado el sistema
sanitario en varias regiones
brasil es el segundo país con más
fallecidos por kobe 19 a nivel mundial
después de eeuu acumulando más de 358
mil muertos desde el inicio de la
pandemia y actualmente es el lugar del
mundo donde más se muere por este virus
con un promedio que supera los tres mil
descensos diarios